[upbeat music]
female narrator: Getting players
to install your game
is one thing.
To be a successful game,
you want your players
to come back again and again.
We've selected ten
compelling ways to do this.
By adding Google Sign In
to your games,
you open up great new ways
to engage with your players,
you reduce the friction
to signing in
because users don't have to
go through
a new account setup flow.
With Google Play Game Services
achievements,
you create a series of tasks
your players can perform
in your game
and let the users know
once they've accomplished them.
Achievements can be
a single goal
or things players do
multiple times.
You can also hide achievements
to prevent spoilers.
The most engaged players
are often motivated
to complete all the achievements
a game offers,
specifically if they're
challenging, secret,
or humorous.
Players love to measure
their skills against others
and leaderboards do just that.
You can create
up to 70 leaderboards
with Google Play Game Services.
Getting daily, weekly,
all-time leaderboards
to track players' scores
so they can compare their
results with their friends
or the public.
By providing saved games with
Google Play Game Services,
you can bring players back
to where they left off
between sessions and
you can let them switch devices
and continue playing between
their smartphone or tablet
or Android TV.
Nothing engages players
like the challenge
of beating another player.
With Google Play Game Services,
you can easily add multiplayer
to both your real-time
and turn-based games.
With the Nearby Connections API,
players can take on
their friends in the same room,
on different devices.
Add quests to introduce
time bound in-game challenges
that players can complete
to earn rewards.
You can issue quests
without updating your app
for specific dates and
reward players who complete them
with in-game items.
Player analytics will give you
information
on the behavior of players
in your game.
You'll get detailed
revenue statistics,
player retention data,
player progression data,
and more.
You can also set and track
daily revenue targets
to assess the monetary success
of your game.
These insights will help you
improve your game
and make it even more attractive
to your users.
Flows in Play Game's
player analytics
will show you how players
progress through your game
and spot where they disengage.
Maybe a level is too hard
to complete.
Perhaps a game feature
is too difficult to find.
And which are the features
the players come back to
time and time again?
Use this information to improve
and update your game.
With AdMob and Google Analytics
you can target your ads
to different types of users
so that they're more relevant,
which will be an improved
user experience.
For example,
you could target users
who have already made a purchase
from your game
with an ad promoting
another in-game product,
while targeting users
who have never bought anything
with regular ads.
The look and function
of your game
is important to you
and your players,
so keep that feel
with your ads too.
Using native ads,
you can customize ads
and make your AdMob campaigns
a more engaging part
of your game experience.
For more information
on engaging your players
and driving game use,
head over
to the distribute section
of the Android developer
website.
If you want more tips
on how to improve your app
or game's performance
and build a better app business,
check out the other videos
in this series
and download The Secrets
to App Success on Google Play.